james
westbrook into james shot clock is
turned off
[Applause]
porzingis their only shot blocker is out
of the game
james doubled finds ellington corner to
westbrook final seconds out to reeves
three-pointer bang
breeze gives him a three-point lead with
nine tenths of a second remaining no
timeouts for dallas
bullock from half point
oh off the mark and the lakers survive
in overtime
what a finish here in dallas
and i thought he got fouled too
[Applause]
austin reeves won a game
five of six from three-point range 15
points
playing all the crunch town crunch time
minutes
and the lakers win their third in a row
[Applause]
coach how about trusting each other the
extra pass time and time made again
ellenton to westbrook lebron to
ellington ellington the westbrook and
then westbrook finding reeves
yeah good offense
westbrook turns it down finds reeves
and that was right down the middle
and they had a foul to get
the 23-year-old rookie out of oklahoma
who wasn't drafted signed as a free
agent with the lakers
with the biggest moment of his young nba
career
and you're right that's a foul
good pass by westbrook
again puts it on target